welcome back to glamour with me josh
smith and today we're joined by the two
queens
of queerness it's the stars of the
happiest season it's kristen stewart and
mackenzie davis
how are you guys great great
yeah tracking along we are rolling with
it well
i'm so happy that we get this christmas
gift in the form of the happiest season
this year because i was thinking when i
was watching it i think it would help me
and a lot of people i know a lot
when they were growing up but also it's
just
basically a journey of self-acceptance
and respect for others as well
how much for you guys would this story
have helped you
when you're growing up and learning to
understand yourselves
would you say um i would have loved to
have seen this movie
when i was younger um i wasn't as a
teenager
as a younger person or well i mean i
guess what's here even in my early 20s
i still wasn't i still wasn't dealing
with
like you know having to contend with
judgmental energy like in terms of
being around a family who didn't
necessarily accept you or
just being an out gay person
whatever i hadn't like but at the same
time i
i was fully like reacting to the
strangeness of
was basically what i'm saying is like i
would have loved to have seen this movie
but i only know that in retrospect and
sometimes you
need to be shown things before uh
you know you need them and um like i
loved i i always wanted to work with
clea i know for a fact that when i was
watching
um but i'm a cheerleader that i was like
why i love this movie for like probably
pretty solid gay reasons
and didn't know that until like as you
know when i was an adult so you know
if this helps anyone who's unaware or
aware of the fact that
sometimes it's hard to say who you are
around every group of
people then that makes me trey happy
i love that and i think it will make a
lot of people trey happy mackenzie how
would it help to you
do you think yes
um it's hard to be like well this the
first game
studio rom-com was actually good for
straights because um
[Laughter]
most importantly this is why
representation
matters i know that phrase has sort of
lost a bit of meaning because it's like
a
should be on a flag but it really does
because
it doesn't only help the people who are
being represented in the thing it also
normalizes a thing that
up until that point maybe hasn't been
normalized in mainstream entertainment
and i think i don't know i feel like i
went to a pretty progressive
high school and grew up in a very
liberal environment that was very
accepting but i look back at things that
happen in high school and the way i
think more with
boys the way that gay boys were treated
or whispers about gayness
uh and it wasn't normalized it wasn't
something that was like treated with
open arms acceptance and i think if
there were movies like this and if
that's what we went to see on the
weekends
it would not be cool sorry i'm not
including myself in this
to be clear um but there just was a
culture of homophobia
even in the most sort of liberal
communities and i think
not having representative stories that
normalize it
are the culprit for that sort of
homophobia oh my god 100
like representation is so important and
that's why we've got to keep talking
about it because someone said to me the
other day they were like
you know we won't have equality until
people just don't have to come out full
stop right
and i was thinking about this movie when
i was watching it but it's so important
to have these kind of
coming-of-age and realization stories
why do you think it's still important to
tell
these sort of like coming out and
reconciliation stories
in 2020 do you think i mean it's a
really like
fringy perspective to think that it's
completely
like that the fear has been sucked out
of the idea of
of telling everyone you know uh it would
be a really really sort of naive
lee optimistic or kind of just ignorant
um
way to approach i mean like look at look
at where i mean
look at where we're at just here in the
states where i think it's a really
i'm so happy to be in a movie that is
inviting and and part of a conversation
that can be argumentative and
and sort of divisive it is like it is a
the movie has open arms and it is it is
not even judgmental of the people that
are judgmental in the movie
to think that we're not as divided as we
are is actually just um
it's not very helpful because it's not
real and
and like i'm i'm the most sort of like
optimistic like glass half full
person but at the same time i think this
movie
could be good for people that don't
necessarily
always lack judgment i mean it really is
like in inviting people to
we could be loud and aggressive with a
raw kind of more in-your-face indie
movie and i want to make a bunch of
those i want to make a bunch of
like you know uh you know with
other other perspectives embedded in
things that are sort of harder to digest
but i think it's really important to be
like no look like
we're really nice too like and we're
just like you
and like don't laugh with us it's not
you know what i mean so
that's the spirit it's the relationship
story full stop and that
no label can put on that that's what's
so special about it
i think you guys have made such an
incredible movie and i think it's going
to help so many people
so just so many clicks to both of you
for creating it so thank you so much
thank you